[Music]
yeah good title
good title these are coffee table books
that nobody wanted maybe we can figure
out why by looking at for example this
one is called mazes for idiots yes these
are just pretty simple mazes those too
but if you think those are simple check
out this one on the back it gives you a
lot of leeway
yeah that's either the easiest maze in
the world or the hard dude if you think
about it yeah okay look at this one now
this is weird
that was that was little under my knee
not yeah no no it was good I like okay
polka those ha have you ever wished you
could own a collection let me get some I
know I know I love I love it
have you ever wished you could own a
collection of photographs featuring
magicians being stabbed by prison
inmates well now you can with Abra
Cadabra
[Applause]
oh no and then that guy that is right in
the kidneys Erica Sabra all right I hope
they say it as they do it yeah Sandra
you know they do you know they do here's
one NFL players God likes more than Tim
Tebow that's right here's God blocking
for Adrian Peterson right there yeah
yeah here's Harry is handing a touchdown
to Calvin Johnson right there
here he is guiding Peyton Manning's
throws it's a touchdown and here he is
just watching Tim Tebow gets sacked and
not Gary all right okay we all know that
Bruce Banner turns into the Hulk right
well this is a comic book as coffee
through a book is probably pretty boring
it's The Adventures of totally cured
Bruce Banner
he's totally cured that area shopping at
IKEA yeah even if he got enraged it
wouldn't matter what happened here he's
doing some light lifting right there
nice there is teaching physics to some
students that's wow what a terrible idea
yeah for a coffee table book and for a
piece of comedy yep now
[Applause]
[Music]
that one was sent in by benedict
cumberbatch by the way so blame him
don't blame me all right here's one
you're gonna like animals with really
bad comb-overs that's just fun eating
his sweets wondering is anybody dying
this
there's even vanity in the animal world
this is fun
this is stoned people laughing at the
name stoned wheat fence look at that
there's a guy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
right now and then I bought this one I
can't believe this wasn't didn't Suggs
it might be the best yeah it's a company
book called find the guy with the boner
oh boy let's see if you can find an
areas on djursland
[Applause]
if we can find the guy where is he
and finally well oh my god
stricken with grief
[Applause]